Church no yay let me explain to you I'm
not doubting what you don't care I do
care you don't care about me you don't
care about my people I care about me I
care about my people so as for me to
stand up and God forbid I step on
someone's toes while I'm at it it's not
some monsters you stepped on the entire
Jewish people's toes with a very deeply
inflammatory tweet which I think you've
now accepted you shouldn't have phrase
that way it's taken a bit of time to get
there but I think you have accepted that
right
have you accepted that you've put no
effort into understanding how I got
there
I I don't think I don't think honestly
10 years from now honestly I don't think
there is apologize to me about this
interview I'm not you're going to
apologize to me about this interview
within the next 10 years no I'm not
because here's the thing my words I
don't doubt you've had it's very
one-sided it's very it's very
white-sided
it's very like it's not it's not
white-sided I'm not doubting you've had
business issues I'm saying the way to
respond to that is to millions of people
Jewish people millions of people
millions of people have had Defcon 3 on
their contracts right you didn't you
didn't say that you didn't say that said
millions of people well I open it up not
I didn't but now I'm saying it now okay
so now what I think you should say I
think you should say to the Jewish
people I'm sorry for the offensive
language I used in that tweet I wouldn't
do that again this is what I really
meant I think people would respect you
if you said that I don't know why you
can't just say that house let me you
know you know you know when I'll say it
when I sit down with the people who
write out the contracts for the NBA and
for the NFL and for professional music
and for uh acting contracts we need to
go to the top lawyers the top execs the
owners of the stadiums the owners of the
football teams and the owners of the
record labels and we're going to put
them all in one room and we're going to
read every let's go top 10 in each one
of these categories right let's read
Michael B Jordan why would any of us why
would any of that hey bro hey hey bro I
ain't finished I ain't finished my
sentence
has anything to do with regret hey boy
don't finish I told you
oh don't treat me like a boy then I'm
gonna finish my sentence or my idea
nothing you're saying has got anything
to do with the Tweet cool
so I was in the middle of a sentence boy
okay so are you going to allow me to
finish my sentence yes
if you then answer my question Okay so
okay so I'm gonna tell people when I
would apologize for the tweet this is
what has to happen first
I need all of the top Executives in
Hollywood I need the top Executives at
the NBA and at the NFL we'll do those
two sports specifically and I want the
top Executives in music dealing with
publishing dealing with uh like Spotify
and apple music and uh Universal Music
and all the topics that uh let's do like
five topics X there and I want to look
at the top 10 earners and each one of
those fields contracts openly we want to
compare and contrast the contracts and
then once we open that conversation and
we need to do it on a platform live with
lawyers asking questions and we'll and
we'll have the top lawyers like a Johnny
Cochran Robert Kardashian level legal
team you know looking at all of these
contracts together after that moment
happens then I will say
I'm sorry
okay if that's your position interview
adjourned love you
okay that's the end of the interview
I'm not I get I just get the feeling
from you that you're you're obviously a
complex character brilliant in many ways
fascinating like I say compelling uh you
have a huge appeal to millions of people
around the world it just seems to me
that occasionally your mouth gets you
into trouble and that perhaps on
reflection sometimes you look back and
wish you hadn't said things is that
accurate
nah not really
because
the things I say are on behalf of God
like it's not always Godly because I'm a
man but God is definitely using me
you're you're uh Catholic faith all
right what's your background Catholic
yeah
well we're we're working for God here
and it's just like with black people now
with entertainment we're coming into
wealth but all the other you know black
people with anywhere near
uh my amount of wealth would never cross
the lines of you know taboos inside of
the media that I would that actually we
used to in rap all these words we used
to say these so it's all these like
words that are being removed from our
vocabulary words that evoke emotion
don't you feel like the salt is being
taken out of our our food you know look
at Dune the people who control the salt
controlled all the money and people are
trying to control the salt and it's salt
in our language that's why I'm I I will
not apologize for
uh having a bit of salt in my words I
will say hey this can be improved on but
it's like hey look I'm gonna update
you're looking at
the gods iPhone 100. we are God's iPhone
right if you think about it we're his
favorite creation we were made in His
image and we need updates and Society
capitalism media and thought police have
been stopping us from our updates we
have to have a thought and then we have
to
actualize it I like the word actualize
better than execute because it executes
a negative word we discussed this we
have to actualize